welcome back dear viewers of SCP
explained we hope you've been keeping
well and we also hope that your health
insurance covers blown Minds because
today we're using our trademark
anomatron 6000 to pit an anomalous
Legend against another Marvel Legend
that's right it's scp-682 versus Dr
Michael morbius of the 2022 cinematic
Masterpiece morbius of course there is
one issue that we should share with you
before we begin we haven't actually seen
morbius however here's the wonderful
thing statistically you haven't either
in fact we tried to get the animatron
6000 to process morbius as raw data for
the simulation but our antivirus
software kept stopping it intriguing so
instead we simply hit randomized traits
on the animatron so it's free to use
Advanced AI could conceive what morbius
is like and what his abilities probably
are and as far as you or I know it might
even be correct so let's get this show
on the Road and see if the hard to
destroy reptile could hone against its
own at Cinema's most tragically memed
upon superhero prepare for perhaps the
most absurd and ridiculous video with
the exception of the Among Us video that
we've ever released on here in other
words it's morbin time it began as many
bizarre SCP Foundation stories do with
scp-682 cracking the glass of its acid
tank and preparing to spill chaos and
Terror onto site 19. for most people
even seeing actual footage of this would
be a life-defining traumatic incident
for most season Foundation researchers
it was just another Sunday when 682
busted through the nearest wall like a
psychopathic reptilian Kool-Aid man
while guards engaged in the futile task
of trying to subdue it with small arms
fire the senior researchers languidly
made their way to the nearest secure
Panic Room and hunkered down as was
standard protocol for scp-682 escapes
all available mobile task force units
would be dispatched single focused on
cutting the lizard back down to size but
the problem was this wasn't just any
other Sunday it was Super Bowl Sunday
and seeing as most mobile task force
operatives are incredibly tough and
manly they generally love football and
promise they definitely come and take
down 682 as soon as the game was over
this would be one thing if scp-682 was
content to just terrorize the usual
denizens of Psych 19 today but no it'd
been a while since the hard to destroy
reptile had tasted civilian flesh and he
intended to rectify that toot sweet in a
state of murderous Fury 682 barged
through wall after wall with the effort
that a normal human might walk through
rice paper soon enough it was free from
the dribe gray walls of the containment
site and feeling the sun on its scales
once more such a lovely day out with the
distant sound of people laughing and
chatting and children playing happily
with their pets 682 predictably found
this disgusting and resolve to destroy
them all and with all those mobile task
force operatives swigging beer eating
peanuts and giggling at amusing
celebrity cameos in Super Bowl Halftime
ads there would be nobody who would stop
682 from completing its dastardly task
except of course one man Dr Michael
morbius while 682 was escaping morbius
was sitting on the deck of his private
yacht drinking a martini glass full of
two percent milk because morbius
understands the importance of having
healthy bones he was listening to a
fantastic podcast about the Curative
powers of beef jerky when high above the
SCP Foundation activated the morb signal
a batman-esque light shining up in the
sky in the shape of a clown this was bad
morbius paused his podcast and prepared
himself finishing the last of his milk
and washing out the glass so it didn't
get smelly he raised his arm and
summoned the morb orb a glowing red ball
that seemed to be the source of his
powers according to a number of internet
memes he clutched the orb feeling its
power flow through him as he made a
small prayer to his Guardian deity the
late David Bowie and with that he took
flight twin Jets of fire blasting out of
his shoes like rocket ships he could
only hope that he'd be able to intercept
as cp682 before it was too late
meanwhile scp-682 was indulging in one
of his favorite hobbies just killing
lots of people he'd invaded the American
city of San Fran angliss New York which
was known for being the biggest
population of people within the
proximity of Psych 19. 682 was truly
rampaging he knocked the ice cream cones
out of children's hands causing them to
weep profusely he literally kicked dogs
and he also murdered a number of adults
with his vicious fangs and Claws the
local police attempted to stop him but
they were hopelessly outmatched they
attempted to Cuff the monster several
times only to find out that by the time
they were halfway through trying to read
the Beast it's Miranda rights he would
break free Rampage yet again all in all
682 was having a grand old time and was
delighted that nobody was coming to stop
its Rampage of utter Devastation it
seemed almost as though the Rampage
would never end until a dark shadow fell
over the ravenous reptilian monster it
turned up its head to see a new foe
floating above it was it a bird was it a
plane no it was Dr Michael morbius of
course wielding his trademark flaming
Trident of Justice another lamb to the
slaughter 682 growled are you ready to
meet your end Morpheus laughed and shook
his head I don't know who you are you
scaly monster but for hurting all these
innocent people you're about to get more
done and with that he threw his flaming
Trident at the reptile striking Brave
and true but it wasn't enough 682 had
developed incredibly strong reflexes
after years of the foundation's attempts
on its life so morbius would need to try
a lot harder than just using his classic
beloved Trident to end this fight even
then before morbius had a chance to
think up another method of attack 682
had adapted and switched to the offense
two great dragon-like leathery Wings
unfurled on the monster's back and it
took to the air lunging towards morbius
with fangs born in claws at the ready
before morbius knew it the creature's
Jaws were ready to close around his head
thankfully at this moment another one of
morbius's classic superpowers comes into
play his short-range teleportation
abilities in a moment of reflex that
would impress 682 morbius teleported out
of the monster's path remanifesting
instantly floating a few feet away 682
growled in irritation of course it would
never be so easy it said the foundation
always sends one of its freaks to
distract me you may think you're strong
but really you're just another puppet
I've never heard of this Foundation
morbius quipped back and I'm not your
standard hero either I really blur the
line between hero and villain entirely
in fact before morbius could finish
explaining what a complex character he
was if you could even use that word 682
flew after him again this time however
morbius was ready he lifted up his arms
and Unleashed another one of his
patented attacks opening up human mouths
in the palms of his hands which
Unleashed miniature yet still extremely
powerful air-to-air missiles the
missiles blasted out and struck 682
causing an impressive explosion but 682
was well versed in explosions it kept
flying after morbius he needed to get
out of here fast or he'd become a
lizard's lunch morbius turned and flew
in the opposite direction the hard to
destroy reptile hot on his heels the
first step of course would be to get
away from populated areas to limit
collateral damage no matter what
happened morbius refused to let this
mysterious entity harm more people you
cannot run forever 682 to ground your
wretched life will be brought to a slow
and painful end stranger they were
passing over the water now flying at
Quantum speeds watching the Pacific
Ocean whiz past beneath them that's when
morbius noticed it and had an epiphany a
volcano and by the looks of the smoke
Rising above it an active one too
morbius had a plan now but to execute it
he'd need perfect speed and timing he
stopped in midair as the Beast flew
towards him but moments before 682 could
make contact morbius grabbed it
executing a perfect mid-air suplex and
tossed the Roaring Beast directly down
into the volcano below for any other
monster this would be the end of it but
for 682 a double triple or even
quadruple tap was often required to
reliably incapacitate it morbius's work
was not done he flew down towards the
volcano ready to engage in the next
hectic stage of battle bet you're not
feeling so cocky now you nasty reptile
Morpheus yelled but there reptile in
question was too busy flailing around in
impossibly hot magma to reply at the
time such is the way when falling into
an active volcano
scp-682 burnt and chart but still alive
began to crawl from the top of the
volcano wheezing out smoke and Ash how
could such a strange confusing creature
have been such a formidable opponent no
matter it will destroy this Morpheus it
might just take a little longer than
expected little did the unfortunate
reptile know morbius Was preparing his
next weapon perfect for immobilizing
this ornery monster an eight ball in a
gym sock forming a kind of dangerous
makeshift flail it was the kind of
lethal improvised weapon that would
strike fear into even the strongest of
enemy combatants and now scp-682 would
learn to fear its power as the flame
broiled reptile began to stand perhaps
preparing to adapt to its latest set of
injuries morbius began relentlessly
beating the hard to destroy reptile with
the 8 ball sock dazing it with repeated
brutal strikes that never seemed to stop
morbius had learned this technique from
years of being involved in vicious bar
fights normally caused by him cheating
at darts this can stop any time you want
Morpheus yelled you just need to stop
getting back up initially 682 wanted to
remain defiant but even it could not
deny that being struck again and again
by the eight ball sock was actually
extremely painful was it really worth
the fight after performing some quick
mental calculations
scp-682 determined that no it probably
wasn't time to throw in the towel okay
okay 682 said mostly just annoyed at
this point I'll stop rampaging honestly
you just took all the fun out of it 682
just sighed and laid on the ground
exhausted slowly regenerating from its
injuries morbius smiled content with his
victory who knows how many people he'd
saved by luring the screech away from a
population Center by this point the
Super Bowl was over and the legions of
mobile task force operatives who
technically should have done this hours
ago finally decided to suit up and take
care of business it didn't take long for
Black Tactical helicopters full of
foundation soldiers to triangulate the
location of the volcano where the end of
682 and morbius's epic battle had taken
place it wasn't long after that that
there were copious Foundation boots on
the ground this story of course has a
happy ending mobile task force agents
successfully recaptured scp-682 and
returned it to its containment cell in
site 19 and in the process of recovery
they mistook Dr Michael morbius for the
actor Jared Leto and shot him roughly 30
times in the chest with armor-piercing
rounds killing him instantly want an
anomaly of your own check out
www.scpswag.com for high quality SCP
merch now go and check out scp-096
versus siren head and scp-076 able vs
chain saw man who has the most lethal
weapon for more Wild versus battles